students return to Stoneman Douglas High
School in Florida today two weeks after
the massacre that took the lives of 17
today we have breaking developments on
the investigation
Florida's House has issued subpoenas to
the Broward County Sheriff's Office
School Board and several local
governments in its evaluation of what
went wrong will Sheriff Israel released
their surveillance video showing the
police response to the mass shooting a
lot of controversy over that response
meanwhile over in our nation's capitol
earlier the president sat down with
members of Congress from both sides of
the aisle to discuss changes to our
nation's gun laws we're gonna come up
with some ideas hopefully we can put
those ideas in a very bipartisan bill it
would be so beautiful that one bill that
everybody could support we have to do
something very decisive number one you
can take the guns away immediately from
people that you can a judge easily or
mentally ill I don't want mentally ill
people to be having guns you know you
rate movies for different things maybe
you have to also write them for terror
for what they're doing and what they're
all about some of you people are
petrified of the NRA you can't be
petrified they want to do what's right
and they're gonna do what's right I
really believe that Kimberly so the
president came up with some basic ideas
like not selling guns to people under 21
he wants more of a universal not quite
you know but better background checks
and and then there's the question
sitting out there about assault weapons
what do you think yeah well I think that
you know it makes sense when you sit
home and you listen to this and you
think about the perspective of you know
we would like some uniformity and
conformity in terms of background checks
we would like all the states to have
somewhat of a similar background check
that is thorough that's comprehensive
and then people actually comply with
that by turning in the information
updating the database to make sure that
it is current and active it really calls
for that because it's so important in
terms of a public safety perspective and
to make sure that people if they are
troubled and they are having issues that
the most recent information is compiled
and uploaded in the system to be
available to law enforcement the
different agency
semental healthcare professionals to
know who they're dealing with but I want
that too wouldn't you want that you want
that kind of consistency across the
board so that if you go into Alabama
it's not different than say if you go
into California while at the same time
respecting the constitutional rights and
the Second Amendment and people's right
to bear arms and part of that includes
going through these checks and Jesse the
president said today he still likes the
idea of arming teachers then he says to
the meeting but I understand a lot of
you don't like that idea and we just
recently had a report of a teacher with
a gun having a little incident I think
it was in Georgia so where do you think
that stands that's a tough one I think
there's a lot of disagreement on that
issue and it depends where you are in
the country and people in Manhattan
think that's wild and then you go out to
anywhere else and they think oh yeah
that's normal a lot of states already do
it there was a key moment I thought
today where the president was kind of
mocking senator Toomey from Pennsylvania
about being beholden to the NRA and they
asked him about raising the age limit
and Toomey had a really great response
and he said well mr. president there's a
lot of 18 19 and 20 year old men and
women in my state of Pennsylvania that
want to use an AR for fun for target for
hunting why should we deny those
law-abiding people their constitutional
Second Amendment rights and the
president kind of sat back and he said
all right well he looked at Manchin and
he said yet you guys really have to get
together on that because that's going to
be a critical issue but that on the on
the Broward County thing we're looking
at information now from sources it said
that the people that showed up the
police officers were told not to go in
unless they had body cameras and none of
them had body cameras the EMTs that
showed up we're told not to go in one of
the EMTs told Fox News everything I was
trained on mass casualty events says
they did the wrong thing
training since Columbine has been first
responders police go in immediately with
paramedics so they had this
de-escalation policy at the Broward
County Sheriff's Department and they had
this other program called the promise
program where they don't arrest students
for criminal activity and then you get
the point where he appoints his friends
to that position and he was also
involved in the Fort Lauderdale
shooting at the airport which went
horribly wrong and he was castigated for
that radio transmissions went down the
Fort Lauderdale shooting as well radio
transmission suspiciously went down in
this shooting too and now he's saying
that that they called the house 23 times
he responded turns out it was twice that
this guy this sheriff is a real villain
and I don't like what he's done how he's
conducted himself and it looks like the
Florida Legislature is going to take
some action against this guy so there's
a lot of stories in there Jesse but we
got to move on but I just wanted to say
to you Dana Dick's Sporting Goods has
now come out and said they will not sell
assault weapons they're not gonna sell
any gun hand gun I saw it Zweifel any
gun to someone who's under 21 and
they're not going to sell high-capacity
magazines so I don't it could be that
this is a good PR move for them but it's
also you know you are making a decision
about selling a product maybe they
weren't maybe their sales weren't very
good
maybe someone hurt them that bad on the
bottom line maybe it will actually
increase sales if people decide that
might be a good place to go and if you
don't mind I just want to comment on
these sessions that the president is
having there's something very special
about them especially but if you think
about do remember that open session that
President Obama had on Obamacare early
on and Paul Ryan was there and the
president took a real shot at Paul Ryan
took a shot of McCain to Cain and that
same event and I just remember I was 20
2009 maybe early 2010 and it set
bipartisan relations way back and it
doesn't get back on track until there's
some moments where there's some crises
on the budget where they have to get
together in these settings the president
is calling members of the Senate by
their first name not disrespectfully but
in a way that is actually quite friendly
he's forcing people to come to the table
and it is not without risk to have open
camera right there where anybody could
come out and say anything and I find
that the members actually feel confident
enough to say something in front of the
president in front of the cameras that
is not showboating and I'm not exactly
sure what's going to happen if they
continue to have these open forums and
nothing results from them and I think
they'll get a little bit old right but
right now it's very special I'll just
say this bill don't would you yeah I'll
build on what you said what's most
important I think is the conclusion at
the end he says I like manchin-toomey
when Steve Scalise put his hand
says I want to get concealed-carry in
that he goes Steve I'm your biggest fan
but that's never gonna work not on this
bill I won't go back to that didn't
Dianne Feinstein he goes hey can I get
uh can I get weapons of war involved net
and he goes guys what do you think that
like I don't know he goes mr. president
you tell them they'll do it and they all
laugh and tell you truth this makes me
realize if you could follow me on this
why the apprentice worked because the
boardroom is actually real I was that's
the way he conducts his life so would
they would edit that and do a good job
on it but for the most part those
celebrity sat in front of him and they
were or the real people and he that's
how he acts imagine so fire them so he
this communications team once a day over
the last four days has sat all these
people around him and said mr. Trump mr.
president beep mr. president and he sat
there and I remember Joe Manchin said I
don't like being senator because I'm I
really don't do anything he's like hey
anything done it's governor I got to get
to do things now he's in the game he
just said now before we walked out if he
was president this was our president
2013 we would have got stuff passed
after Sandy Hook
Wow that's a Democrat from West Virginia
I know he's got to get reelected but
still it was unsolicited well I think a
lot of people would like to know the
president's positions but I hear what
you're saying this is the president
style is to say you guys we want to get
something done I think it probably will
work better well let's see what happens